welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar in vivo Surgical
models for drug discovery hidden
pitfalls and their avoidance it is
presented by Matthew flagel senior
associate scientist in behavioral
pharmacology and surgery at Biogen my
name is Judy Arak and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring this educational web
seminar presented by lab Rhodes lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming Matthew flagel I
will now turn the presentation over to
him very nice to virtually meet all of
you and today I am going to be covering
several things related to how to use
properly use I should say in vivo
Surgical models or drug discovery as the
title suggests there are plenty of traps
and pitfalls step into so I'm going to
try and give you kind of a jumping
around overview of things that would be
very useful for you to keep in mind when
you're planning these types of studies
so to start off with this is me many
many years and many pounds ago I've been
doing this for quite some time
and again I have been able to see an
awful lot of mistakes and errors but
also learn from a law
very skilled and knowledgeable people
and how to do these types of studies and
have you get the actually you need them
to be successful so again it's just a
little bit of overview some of the
things that we're gonna touch on or
fairly advanced surgical procedures and
so I put in things this organ transplant
that I had done several years back
Faraday or des CNS surgery in canines
and so forth and the thing to keep in
mind is when we think about the
possibility for complications in vivo
surgery these are the kind of procedures
that were thinking we're thinking of
something that is comparatively rare is
comparatively seldomly done and only a
few people do and if you get nothing
else out of this talk what I really like
you to get is all of these things matter
at the most basic surgical procedure
that you could use in your discovery
pipeline it's not all transplants
central nervous system surgery and what
have you putting in a cannula improperly
for drug delivery can completely destroy
the results of your study so the
concepts that I'm going to give you
again kind of a high-level overview that
are applicable across the board please
don't think that just because you're
doing a commonly performed surgery that
the requirements of it are somehow less
surgery is surgery
you are invading the body cavity or
invading the underlying tissue of a lab
animal living creature it's fought with
opportunities and welfare as only goes
without saying if you're in focus I'm
going to speak with my assistants yes
you might want to find an alternative
that's not
all right so here's the key if you will
all of the molecules that you come up
with all of the devices that your
engineers develop at some point in the
process they're going to have to go into
lab animal studies for efficacy for
safety testing or toxicity levels and
there's probably going to be several of
them in a fairly well-defined pathway
and unfortunately oftentimes the people
and the groups were conducting these
studies are kept very separate from the
actual discovery teams that's
unfortunate because the level of work
and the applicability and translate
ability of the work that Evo study teams
are doing it's going to directly affect
the success or failure if your compound
or device but more simply and studies
run poorly and have a good compound fail
you have a bad compound have it's
failures masked until much later in the
discovery development even into the
safety process when you spend hundreds
to thousands of FTV hours spent millions
to tens of billions of dollars in this
day and age when we're all trying to
make do with less whether we frankly
want to or not you don't have the luxury
of wasting these kinds of resources and
it should go without saying as well
you're not just wasting resources you're
wasting the bias of the lab animals that
you're working and I would propose to
you that if that is not a major concern
to you if the welfare of your test
subjects is critical people what we're
concerned about probably see let's call
it another career path so let's move and
amplify that just a little bit more they
are a specialty in their own right
oh please don't ever assume that an Evo
study is a sick thing that requires
minimal skill and
Ariane's and I've heard numerous times
over the past 25 years the horrible old
well anyone can probably do it and it's
not completely untrue anyone can do it
it's just they're gonna do it really
really Oh
if you've invested major portion of your
team's life and budget into yeah Molitor
or a therapeutic or a device kind of owe
it to yourself to make sure that people
putting it in doing the best job
possible and the thing with surgery is
25 years ago
surgery was probably not as if most
drugs cover it backwards but in this day
and age there aren't a lot of compounds
that make it all of reinstatement
process without going into lab animals
but that's some sort of special
intervention could be radiant lemon tree
implant for cardiovascular monitoring
could be a catheter for drug delivery or
sample collection but it's pretty safe
to bet at some point in the pathway
somewhere down the line someone is going
to be doing surgery we better hope why
so things to think about when you are
planning that study and you as a
discovery team you can always have these
thoughts because again you pick the
wrong species if you pick the wrong
strain your study may fail through no
fault of what you're using but because
they selected the wall anatomy is
different keep in mind most lab animals
are quadrupeds walk around on all fours
which means that their organs are
pushing on different tissues they're an
atomic structure is if you think that
doesn't affect how the tools and devices
work I'm afraid to tell you you're
completely wrong
the effective stress on the heart
changes our decision though that depends
versus my heads will change where is
that going in
sighs if picking something topical in
the news you're looking at traumatic
brain with all of the things either with
NFL players or sculptors and online a
two-round brain and mouse cannot be
accelerated image of the grand brain
there may be other one is grounded but
if we're trying to lightly mimics the
anatomy itself they mean for results
there's an atomic clearance even between
us brains one strain of mouse c57 black
my mistake Alex Lewis rat is not the
same as a Sprague Dawley
wrapped a purpose bread beetle dog it's
not stained how cinnamomum is London my
name's Austin
there's an atomic theory it's the matter
we've either brain anatomy which may
directly affect how your mind works the
thickness of implant completely
something else somewhat esoteric of when
you're viewing for instance of ocular
portal toughness and the fibrotic
structure within it contains the action
not just within by an injected test art
and also just keep in mind these brains
no thrift over time else that years ago
here's one of my favorite examples
there's a lot of rain spirits and a lot
of people even down to mice you leave
stereotaxic Alice says the very
beginning first page that all of these
stairs
coordinates we're going to both cream or
Alzheimer's or ALS or MS or what have
you are based on only 26 animals once
drawn at one age a human specific
Wednesday vice very much more in brain
anatomy and rats or gratitude as well
but tend to look at a reference so
they'll find a paper talk about beavers
that they will blindly follow making
sure that it works so there is a real
world of fact of having these
differences so I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time focusing on kind of the overview
selecting right model they're good texts
out there of recommend reading them all
but little things like are you trying to
model the cause of an injury or a
surgical intervention or dosing paradigm
or the result and neither one of those
is necessarily all right are all wrong
but you need to have these types of
questions answered upfront you in a
select a proper longer your the question
to answer I would very strongly
recommend based on scenes about real
successes and seen some groups with real
failures over the years if you are
executing the study based purely on
someone said I had to do it and I'm
checking an arbitrary box yes I have
done this study but you haven't worked
out why you're running in that study
chances are you're going to design it
orally and yes you'll check that box
which will get the information that was
the original reason that you were
required to check that box in first
place you improve the wrong hypothesis
you can't provide ambiguous results um
and at some point and again this day and
age probably very constrained timeframe
you're gonna have to make a decision
based on the results that you get
and to be blunt if they're garbage
your decision is so much more difficult
and if you've ever honestly set up a
study to make your phone count again
fail utterly fail ah you're going to
proceed with the walk date I would
propose to you if you don't have this
type of information wait
doing a bad study rarely if ever is an
advantage over just not doing study at
all it's better to have no data than
compromise it you still going to make a
decision but you know no that is
compromised and again is circle back if
you feel bad a study those are animal
lives that you're wasting ah again that
should be a pretty significant concern
so when you're looking at models and
just in general what do we do we go to
comment we go to the club net we go to
the internet and we start looking up
journals when we find papers papers are
wonderful that's jumping off once but
especially when it comes to in vivo
twerk they tend to be far less useful
than you might hold for simple things
and you reproduce that study of house it
is framing how often you can't and
you're also if you are not looking with
somewhat skeptical eye of the paper
are you sure that the author chose the
right species the right strain the right
technique the right materials the right
approach one of the ones that I've seen
for years years years to this day
they're looking at the histopathology of
surgical site they're looking at an
implanted device and they use highly
reactive materials to just place device
so if I close an incision with the most
reactive suture material as far as I
know in the entire field itself I've
completely destroyed my histopathology
it's completely affected any effect
might get from my implant or my material
or my injection at that site is probably
masked by the fact that I have a hyper
acute inflammatory reaction just based
on the suits right with it and to this
day I see that in movies so don't assume
that they did things right and then red
flags so when you're looking at it in
vivo study look for things like odd
group sizes if they have seven groups
and group one has eight animals -
mesthri animals for has five animals
group 5 has one animal it may be because
those animals are very difficult to get
their genetic cross or what have you
my experience has been when you see that
sort of thing in a paper it's probably
because they had a very high mortality
rate and they're only reporting the ones
that survived we just might calling the
question the procedure that they've done
oh if they have a hundred percent
success
everything looks so perfect that it
looks like it was drawn it made me we're
all susceptible at times to
cherry-picking data and what happened
the study looks too perfect it may be
it's worth anything that with a
skeptical eye investigating you're also
going to find there's often very minimal
technical details I have seen transplant
papers that said we transplanted one
heart from a donor and that's the entire
song of their technical procedure
there's a lot left out there oh it's the
last thing that I would do I'll tell you
what I it's so much easier than when I
started
reach out to the authors of the paper
talk to them directly
it is amazing the important nuggets of
information they're left out of the
papers especially when it comes to
technical details in surgery and don't
be surprised if when you reach out you
find that the person that you talk to
who's actually doing the procedure
it's not reflected on the paper and it
is not uncommon for them to respond with
something along the lines of yeah that's
not how we actually do it maybe you can
get the correct information because I
can tell you from better personal
experience there's nothing better than
spending three months frantically and
great frustration trying to reproduce a
burr to finally reach out to the surgeon
in it and find out that there were two
entry key pieces of information better
not waste your time and again better not
waste a performance last call that kind
of an overview is nation gathering data
animal is a fountain of information if
you are having this often in vivo team
are they doing a even though somewhat
first read for me props and
determination will study oh just because
you have a central nervous system frog
doesn't mean that it's not having
unexpected effects on other organ
systems and when you do a post
euthanasia in proxy and you find that
the kidneys are four times larger than
they should be or if their heart is
dramatically distended at the atrium was
that what you expected no it was an
organ system that you were looking at
still know is something that you
probably want to know as part of the
discovery team about probable
complications absolutely you have to
look at these things are the people
trained bonded they have a protocol
bunches for defrosting but are they
watching the animals during the course
of a study they looking for untold hours
again you are passing your molecule and
your device off to a team they can
completely destroy your research it's
worth a little bit of due diligence to
make sure that they're doing it properly
so here's my my favorite examples
because it's
the simplest things that we do in lab
out it's bills we do oral gavage which
if we can do it that's what we're gonna
want to do it's fairly straightforward
technically it's ideal for translate
ability because most of your medicines
most your molecules administered orally
if at all possible but there's a problem
how you do it can directly affect the
outcome of your study we age if you have
a neutral pH test material that cannot
survive tails and pH and it's dependent
on its origin in large intestine and you
put it into an acidic GI tract your
molecule is probably broken down before
it's ever absorbed it'll look like a
failure and it's technically not because
you never had the chance for the
medication to actually get taken into
the app is the ketubah placed properly
is it placed all the way in the stomach
so that your entire dose is administered
that way or is possibly due to technical
experience what have you is it placed in
the esophagus as well as the tube
running from the mouth to the stomach
and half your test material is passed
back up and spit out onto the cage floor
we also little things like do we use the
four volumes here's the maximum volume
that you give now if it's been eating
and its stomach is full and you
administer a maxval you now you've
distended the stomach what's normal GI
reaction to that it flushes out the GI
Travis quickly as possible typically
lately so what's going to happen is the
test material that you just administer
that you were expecting a certain degree
of uptake over 12 hours of GI transit it
just got shot out the other end and
happen and none of it has been taken off
and that's gonna be variable across your
analyst so again even something as
straightforward as
oral dose of medication if it's done
improperly completely destroy your study
I'm not gonna brush briefly over
training but the people do in your study
and do their surgeries are they trained
have you validated that they're doing a
problem and when was the last time you
validate surgeons drift we change our
technique over time either because we've
learned things were modified our
technique because it's easier or more
straightforward or what have you but it
can mean that we're not doing surgery
the same way that we were when we
validated on come on maybe that will
make a difference but maybe it will is
important to know that um if you have
multiple surgeons have you validated
across the bar they all performing the
surgery the same way again the most
basic surgical procedure by our
medicines probably placing a catheter
for those fight with the catheter a
different place in another surgeon I may
directly affect the uptake on the animal
or create complications of that happen
the most basic surgery but if there's
variability between surgeries results
are quite different through surgery to
surgeon and how do you analyze those
results the surgeons have the time
management and using our economics are
they causing themselves fatigue over the
course of their day so that the animals
that they do at the end of the surgery
day take twice as long and have
significantly more complications are
they managing themselves so that their
quality of work stays consistent oh
we've seen for years and years one of
the truisms is mixed up errors test
groups over the course of the day
because you don't want to have this time
effect once upon a time we thought it
was suited more to a physiologic way
than off to the lab animal itself taking
a cue from human medicine and surgery
we've kind of learned at this point is
because the surgeon fatigues against
sloppy words rushing or wants to get to
lobster wants to go home on time and
they compromised it work
again it's a little thing but it will
affect your study and then specifically
it surgery must health status of your
lab battle this is one of the biggest
pitfalls I've seen from them in a bit of
an advocate for a good decade in half
about this and is this if your animal is
not healthy if it has compromised organ
systems this will change the results of
your experiment . alignment it will
change your results just looking to make
sure that they're walking around and
eating is not sufficient especially if
you are trying to affect target work if
you are doing brain surgery you probably
want to make sure that you're doing it
on a healthy brain if you're doing
cardiovascular surgery you probably want
to make sure that you have a healthy
heart cardiovascular system and this
became very clear to me about 17 years
ago when I started doing cardiac
ultrasound on every lab animal that I
did surgery in large part of Italian
because I just learned how to do
ultrasound but this is my test as this
happened three weeks and in his process
we had a non-movement primate that was
going to Bregenz
elementary surgery and veterinary exam
perfect plug values perfect vegetarian
stand looked perfectly colored and when
I did ultrasound
I found an intraventricular septum that
was so large that it basically closed
off the ventricles and turned the two
chambers that pump blood either into the
block which route the body cardiac
volume on this animal had been chopped
over the amount of blood that was coming
out of the heart was barely a third this
animal most perfectly healthy
we analyzed the tissue it had cardiac
hypertrophy TF regeneration um this
animal would have gone on slay it would
have given us data that we would have
used to evaluate test materials and they
live all and I must speak I'll tell you
this I apologize it's unpublished data
but for what it's worth at this point I
have done cardiac ultrasound or
approximately 2,000 rats that was an
example about seven percent of them had
significant cardiac deficiencies
typically ejection fraction technically
ventricular hypertrophy but that's one
out of twelve significantly comment oh
if you think that your study
unfortunately so focus little bit oily
police are on surgery aseptic technique
is critical absolutely critical or
minimizing contamination our surgical
site we don't want to create some
unemployment factions some clinical and
clinical infections will change your
results some clinical infections so it's
an infection that is dying through the
animal but it's not even grow sleeves or
focus on so you don't see discharging on
see lethargy you don't see noticeable
compromise but their vasculature is
carrying infectious microorganisms
chances are they have partial renal
failure chances are they have
deficiencies in our di gallop wooden
part they have cheese in brain cancer if
you have a subclinical infection that
because of a breach in dura because
you've done brain surgery crosses it the
brain transient lesions which by grows
afterwards this isn't a maybe this is
almost certainty again that is going to
change to change result exactly
technique is pretty do it in humans
although farm animals typically do
surgery on now else too and they get
infected
just the same again slow down their
healing pieces based on toxins the
fiscal degrees which changes the whole
circulation increase the animals
painting this comfort which again is an
animal welfare itch but as I said even
if you can't see the infection that is
present it is dramatically changing all
of the physiological parameters and
again the data has leading change and
unfortunately if you don't eat blood
work if you're not for changes in air
temperature and may well be introducing
these problems never know you know I'm
for years without realizing it trust me
having worked with some groups we've had
that horrible wait don't be a nitrate
and just quick study oh and I'll throw
out there for a septic technique this is
going to hit successfully biomaterial
surgeries I've taken this to the person
who originally taught me surgery or
essentially ago documents pendant all
did this kind of study in it's been
eye-opening
which is simply take a surgical implant
that's proven safe on react save 12 rats
and you get your porous implant in staff
Hortis which is common contaminant pipe
organs you just wrap it around their
finger and then 28 days later you
sacrificed in the animal that
everything's done properly with pure a
second technique great in growth into
the fibers selves everything looks
wonderful getting wonderful continuity
collagen fibers everything
fantastic you send it to your
pathologist this biomaterial this
implant working on past five years they
look at it and they say it's great
interior continued development on it
that's where as a slower magnification
do it it is contaminated all dot product
deema the implant post away leave
inflammatory cascade send it to the
pathologist I'm going to tell you that
you were inclined to spit material is
too reactive and it's not based purely
like what you did and yeah they may be
honest I acted on the state but I can
tell you I'm aware of several
biomaterials dating back to the 50s that
we ran one study one get one chance at
this it's done poorly Thal as you look
terrible and it took decades for that
material to be resurrected again the
gone through so much work to develop
your evolved from so much work to
developing rapidly don't let it fail or
technique not search so so how do you
get your surgeon died out there a bit of
a philosophy which is treating isn't
discipline treating this an art if
you're in surgery you shouldn't want to
be in search you should be passionate
about what you're doing
oh because anything about it how they do
my techniques can completely change the
results in plastic surgeon is rid of the
scar it has the exact same serviceable
toolbox as a surgeon who leaves a giant
swamp
why do they have different results what
are their different outcomes what are
their different plans when they go in
but I'm putting it here if you are
searching
in mind what is important what it's not
I put this picture in as kind of a quick
story I was just learning surgery I was
trying to make prettiest incisions us
doing Neri closings and evil dogs and I
had the most beautiful closures possible
in see they were perfect what I did is I
sacrificed strength of mine closer for
the appearance and so after a few hours
when the animals fortunately were on old
kids so they had plenty of pain
medication and tranquilizers as soon as
they started moving incisions late so I
spent about seven hours in the evening
sold out to the bottom wanna be
anesthetized and brief closing every
time because I went in there long I was
finding it pretty if you have surgeons
there's nothing new
I warn you especially in some regions of
the country this way will make the
stories much philosophy of national how
did Tom Brady it's very very people out
there oh this is a skill set that takes
a lot I'm not just talking transplant
the most basic procedures that dealer
takes practice to get good at its
practice opera sizes minimize damage to
the tissues and maintaining a believed
the working sisters you have to practice
and I'm gonna throw out there there's a
difference between practice competition
practice means trying to do better it
doesn't mean just going through the
motions I live in Massachusetts
I work in Cambridge I spend almost three
hours every day I can tell you right now
my computer stopped making me a better
Drive I'm not trying to avoid but I'm
putting in three hours a day so it's not
just over and over it's trying to do
better it's located a pathologies
investigate all of your results looking
for complications trying to understand
why you have them then fix them many
ways you can set yourself little
challenges can I work with an incision
that is a centimeter long which is
better for the tissue intact am i
following my cases every animal that I
do surgery on I keep tabs on it the life
of that out because especially with
device work you can be without
complications for months and then have a
problem arise at that point of your
comments or your animals and just I
wanted to put this in here but let's not
forget anesthesia is in order to and I
put this in this is a summer project for
one of my technicians fantastic and what
she did is she simply went in mice and
rats to see if they were seeing someone
things
Lana Steve's active on anesthetics a lot
especially with rodents we've depressed
their central nervous system you
depressed
their respiratory centers we've reduced
their instant or next or volume of the
lungs without supplemental oxygen
their o2 saturation should be around 95
to 98 Lvov human drops the system
yourself it's human hospital if you drop
there it's considered a life-threatening
emotions
so keeping our patients what keeping
them oxygenated again in cascades
through this acute damaged
cardiovascular respiratory center
because if your anesthetic all again
today is on you can take hours to days
and again the study so I know I jumped
around a little bit pieces on the
resources around so my goal has been to
provide you whole bunch of things I
started concealer because any one of
these you can follow down against enemy
attacks post out there especially
fantastic why the basic principles and
reasons that he's used translate across
the species but if you are working with
surgeons be sure they're doing things
right because if they're not broken
record I admitted which rotated is it's
a cliche but it also happens to be true
with a lab animal scourging won't reveal
how I do my work will affect the study
and after a while ethically
do this but the saying is you tell me
what the results you want and I can do
the surgery in such a way to maximize
the chance we should be doing it if you
are searching or an anesthetist can't
give an Athlon who these two are alive
we have an ethical obligation to the
humans that our drugs and devices we
have to give our best efforts every
animal sacrifice has to be done
otherwise to waste their lives our time
and again if you're on a discovery team
the always years with that that's all I
have to say or at least all I have time
to say it so thank you very much and
please send your questions Thank You
Matthew for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab rooms for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 27th 2019 and as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thanks for joining us
and we will see you next time bye